أهلاً بكم مجدداً في فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية. اسمي John Wattress وأنا المدير التقني للتعليم في IBM
Quantum. هذا هو الدرس السادس عشر والأخير في السلسلة وموضوع الدرس هو الحوسبة الكمية المتسامحة
مع الأخطاء. على مدار الدروس الثلاثة السابقة رأينا عدة أمثلة على شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية التي يمكنها اكتشاف وتسمح لنا بـ
تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية طالما لم يحدث عدد كبير جداً منها. لكن إذا أردنا استخدام تصحيح الأخطاء في الحوسبة الكمية فهناك العديد من
المسائل التي يجب التعامل معها، بما في ذلك حقيقة أن الـ gate الكمية والقياسات وتحضيرات
الحالات هي نفسها على الأرجح غير مثالية. فمثلاً إذا كنا سننفذ تصحيح الأخطاء على
qubit واحد أو أكثر تم ترميزها باستخدام شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية، فسيتعين علينا فعل ذلك بـ gate وقياسات هي نفسها
لديها فرصة لعدم العمل بشكل صحيح. وهذا يعني ليس فقط الفشل في اكتشاف أو تصحيح الأخطاء بل ربما
إدخال أخطاء جديدة. بالإضافة إلى ذلك نحتاج أيضاً لتنفيذ الحسابات الفعلية التي نريد تنفيذها مرة أخرى بـ gate ليست
مثالية. وبالتأكيد لا يمكننا المخاطرة بفك ترميز المعلومات الكمية من أجل تنفيذ الحسابات ثم
إعادة الترميز بعد الانتهاء لأن الأخطاء قد تضرب عندما تكون حماية شفرة تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية غائبة.
هذا يعني أنه يجب علينا معرفة كيفية تنفيذ الـ gate الكمية مباشرة على الـ qubit المنطقية التي لا تبقى أبداً بدون
حماية شفرة تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية. هذا أمر صعب للغاية لكن من المعروف أنه طالما مستوى الضوضاء
يقع تحت قيمة عتبة معينة فإنه من الممكن فعلاً تنفيذ حسابات كمية كبيرة بشكل تعسفي بشكل موثوق باستخدام عتاد مزعج، على الأقل
نظرياً. وسنناقش هذه الحقيقة بالغة الأهمية لاحقاً في الدرس. إليكم نظرة عامة موجزة على
الدرس. سنبدأ بنموذج أساسي للحوسبة الكمية المتسامحة مع الأخطاء يتضمن مناقشة قصيرة
لنماذج الضوضاء مع منهجية عامة لتنفيذ circuit كمي بشكل متسامح
مع الأخطاء. ثم سننتقل إلى مسألة انتشار الأخطاء في الـ circuit الكمية المتسامحة مع الأخطاء وكيفية
التحكم فيه. بشكل خاص سأناقش تطبيقات الـ gate العابرة التي توفر طريقة بسيطة جداً للتحكم في انتشار
الأخطاء. رغم وجود قيد أساسي يمنعنا من استخدام هذه الطريقة
حصرياً. سأتحدث أيضاً عن منهجية مختلفة تتضمن ما يُسمى بالحالات السحرية وتوفر مساراً مختلفاً للتحكم في انتشار
الأخطاء في الـ circuit الكمية المتسامحة مع الأخطاء. رغم أنها ليست الطريقة الوحيدة المعروفة. وأخيراً الدرس
يُختتم بمناقشة عالية المستوى لنظرية العتبة التي أشرت إليها قبل لحظات.
هذه النظرية تنص على أن الـ circuit الكمية الكبيرة بشكل تعسفي يمكن تنفيذها بشكل موثوق طالما أن معدل الخطأ لجميع المكونات
المعنية يقع تحت قيمة عتبة محدودة معينة. بشكل عام قيمة العتبة هذه
تعتمد على شفرة تصحيح الأخطاء التي نستخدمها وكذلك الخيارات المحددة التي نتخذها للتطبيقات المتسامحة للـ
gate الكمية والقياسات لكنها لا تعتمد على حجم الـ circuit المُنفَّذ. وهذا يعطينا سبباً وجيهاً للاعتقاد بأن الحسابات
الكمية واسعة النطاق ستصبح حقيقة يوماً ما. سنبدأ بمناقشة نموذج أساسي للحوسبة الكمية المتسامحة
مع الأخطاء والذي يعتمد بطبيعة الحال على الـ circuit الكمية وشفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية. لأغراض هذه المناقشة
لنتخيل أن لدينا circuit كمي نأمل تنفيذه مثل الموضح هنا. يصادف أن يكون
هذا circuit نقل كمي يتضمن تحضير الـ EBIT. لكن التفاصيل لا تهم كثيراً في هذه المناقشة. ويمكنك تخيل أن
هذا أي circuit كمي آخر، ربما circuit أكبر بكثير يتضمن تحضيرات حالات وعمليات
أحادية وقياسات. هذا الـ circuit بالطبع يمثل الحالة المثالية وأي
تنفيذ فعلي له لن يكون مثالياً. السؤال الطبيعي هو ما الذي يمكن أن يحدث
خطأً؟ حسناً هناك الكثير مما يمكن أن يحدث خطأً. مثلاً تهيئة الحالات عموماً لن تكون
مثالية. بالطبع الـ gate الأحادية لن تكون مثالية ولا القياسات
كذلك. وعلاوة على ذلك الـ qubit نفسها ستكون عرضة للضوضاء بما في ذلك فك الترابط في كل لحظة من
الحساب حتى عندما لا يحدث شيء لهذه الـ qubit وهي تخزن المعلومات الكمية فقط. بعبارة أخرى تقريباً
كل شيء يمكن أن يحدث خطأً. هناك استثناء واحد مع ذلك أو على الأقل هذا افتراض شائع و
هو أن أي حسابات كلاسيكية معنية على الأرجح لن تكون خاطئة لأنه لجميع الأغراض العملية
الحسابات الكلاسيكية مثالية عملياً. فمثلاً إذا شغّلنا خوارزمية مطابقة كلاسيكية لـ
حساب تصحيحات أخطاء شفرة السطح فلا نحتاج فعلاً للقلق من أن هذا الحساب الكلاسيكي قد يكون خاطئاً. لكن أي شيء يتعلق مباشرة
بالمعلومات الكمية قد يكون كذلك. بالطبع نحتاج نموذجاً دقيقاً نستطيع من خلاله ربط
الاحتمالات لمختلف الأشياء التي قد تسوء. وإذا أردنا يمكننا ابتكار نموذج معقد كما نشاء ليعكس نأمل ما
يحدث فعلاً في الواقع. لكن إذا كان النموذج معقداً جداً فقد يصبح صعباً أو مستحيلاً العمل به أو قول
أي شيء مثير للاهتمام عنه. مثال بسيط جداً على نموذج ضوضاء يدرسه الناس غالباً
هو نموذج الضوضاء العشوائية المستقلة حيث الأخطاء أو الأعطال التي تؤثر على مكونات مختلفة في لحظات
مختلفة أو بعبارة أخرى مواقع مختلفة في الـ circuit تكون مستقلة.
مثلاً يمكننا القول أن كل gate يفشل باحتمال معين وأن انقلابات البت وانقلابات الطور تحدث للـ qubit المخزنة باحتمال
مختلف لكل وحدة زمنية وهكذا. لكن الافتراض هو أنه لا يوجد ارتباط بين
الأخطاء المختلفة. الآن قد تعترض على هذا النموذج لأنه على الأرجح ستكون هناك بعض الارتباطات بين
الأخطاء. مثلاً ربما هناك فرصة صغيرة لحدوث خطأ كارثي يمحو كل الـ qubit دفعة واحدة.
أو ربما الأكثر احتمالاً أن تكون هناك أخطاء محلية لكنها مع ذلك تؤثر على عدة مكونات.
ولا أحد يقول العكس. لكن مع ذلك هذا النموذج يمثل خطاً أساسياً بسيطاً يعبّر
في جوهره عن فكرة أن الطبيعة غير قابلة للتنبؤ لكنها ليست خبيثة وليست تحاول عمداً
تخريب الحسابات الكمية. هناك نماذج ضوضاء أخرى يُقال إنها أكثر واقعية يتم دراستها غالباً. وبغض النظر عن
النموذج الذي نختاره إذا اتضح أن نموذجنا يضللنا وتعلمنا شيئاً جديداً عن الأخطاء في
أي نظام نعمل معه يمكننا بطبيعة الحال صياغة ودراسة نماذج أخطاء مختلفة. بعد ذلك سنلقي
نظرة على استراتيجية أساسية لتنفيذ الـ circuit الكمية بشكل متسامح مع الأخطاء. فلننظر في circuit
كمي منطقي معين أي circuit كمي مثالي نريد تشغيله. مثلاً يمكننا النظر في نفس الـ circuit كما
سبق والذي مُدّ قليلاً لأننا سنحتاج مساحة أكبر قليلاً للتنفيذ المتسامح مع الأخطاء. أولاً
تحضيرات الحالات والـ gate الأحادية والقياسات لن تُنفَّذ مباشرة كـ gate مفردة أو كـ
قياسات أو تحضيرات حالات على qubit مفرد بل ستُنفَّذ بما يُسمى بالأدوات الصغيرة والتي
يمكن أن تتضمن كل منها عدة qubit وعدة عمليات. هنا في هذا المخطط
وضّحت ذلك برسم صناديق بنفسجية حول هذه الأشياء. ويمكنك التفكير في هذه الصناديق البنفسجية كأنها circuit صغيرة أو عمليات
مسمّاة فقط بأي تحضير حالة أو gate ننوي تنفيذه. ثانياً نحتاج لحماية
الـ qubit باستخدام شفرة تصحيح أخطاء. فلن تكون الـ qubit المنطقية نفسها هي التي تربط هذه الأدوات المختلفة بل الأدوات تعمل على
الـ qubit الفيزيائية التي تشفّر هذه الـ qubit المنطقية. ومن الجدير بالتأكيد هنا أن الـ qubit المنطقية التي تهمنا
لا تُكشف أبداً أي أن هذه الـ qubit المنطقية ستقضي حياتها كاملة محمية بأي
شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية نستخدمها. وأخيراً ننفذ تصحيح الأخطاء على الـ qubit المشفّرة
بشكل متكرر طوال الحساب أساساً كلما أتيحت لنا الفرصة. ومن الأهمية البالغة أن نفعل
ذلك. بشكل حدسي مع حدوث الأخطاء تبدأ العشوائية أو عدم اليقين بالتراكم في حالة
الـ qubit ونحتاج للعمل باستمرار لإزالة هذه العشوائية أو الإنتروبيا. وهذا يحدث عبر تصحيح الأخطاء.
فيمكنك التفكير في خطوات تصحيح الأخطاء هذه كأنها ثلاجات منطقية صغيرة أو مضخات حرارة
تسمح للـ qubit المنطقية بالبقاء باردة حتى يعمل الحساب بشكل صحيح.
بمجرد اتخاذ كل هذه الخيارات أي اختيار جميع الأدوات والشفرة وبافتراض نموذج ضوضاء معين هناك
سؤال جوهري يمكننا طرحه على أنفسنا وهو: هل هذا يساعد فعلاً؟ هل نجعل الأمور أفضل أم
نجعلها أسوأ؟ إذا كانت الضوضاء كثيرة جداً فقد نجعل الأمور أسوأ فعلاً
تماماً كما أن شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit تجعل الأمور أسوأ إذا كانت فرصة الخطأ عالية جداً.
لكن إذا كانت الضوضاء تحت عتبة معينة فكل هذا العمل الإضافي سيوصلنا إلى مكان ما. وكما سنناقش قرب نهاية الدرس
تنفتح مسارات لتقليل الخطأ أكثر. في هذا الجزء من الدرس سنناقش انتشار الأخطاء في الـ circuit الكمية المتسامحة
مع الأخطاء ذات البنية الأساسية التي وصفتها للتو. يتبين أن هذا
مصدر قلق رئيسي لأننا إذا لم نتمكن من التحكم في انتشار الأخطاء فإن الأخطاء ستطغى بسرعة على جهود تصحيح
الأخطاء. لكن إذا تمكنا من التحكم في انتشار الأخطاء فإن شفرتنا ستكون لديها فرصة أفضل بكثير
للمواكبة بحيث يمكن تصحيح الأخطاء بمعدل عالٍ بما فيه الكفاية للسماح لحساباتنا بأن
تعمل. نقطة البداية لهذه المناقشة هي إدراك أن gate ثنائية الـ qubit أو gate متعددة الـ qubit بشكل
أعم يمكن أن تنشر الأخطاء حتى عندما تعمل بشكل صحيح.
مثلاً لننظر في gate تحكم-NOT. ولنفترض أن خطأ X يحدث على الـ qubit المتحكم قبل تنفيذ gate التحكم-NOT
حسناً خطأ X يعمل تماماً مثل gate X. ونجد أن
الـ circuit على اليسار يكافئ ذلك على اليمين حيث تحدث أخطاء X على كلا الـ qubit بعد gate
التحكم-NOT. هذا انتشار للأخطاء لأن الموقع المؤسف لخطأ X على اليسار يحوّله فعلياً
إلى خطأين X على اليمين. ولن نتمكن أبداً من تجاوز هذا. طالما نستخدم gate تحكم-NOT ستكون هناك دائماً
فرصة لحدوث خطأ X على الـ qubit المتحكم قبلها مباشرة والذي ينتشر بعدها إلى خطأين X
بعدها. لكن كما سنرى طالما نتخذ خطوات للحد من الضرر الذي يسببه هذا سنكون بخير. وبالمناسبة
نفس الظاهرة تحدث عندما يكون لدينا خطأ Z على الـ qubit الهدف قبل gate تحكم-NOT مباشرة. وقد ناقشنا هذا
سابقاً ويمكنك التحقق من هذه المتساويات ببساطة بإجراء عمليات الضرب أو يمكنك التحقق منها باستخدام
Qiskit. الخلاصة أن هذا سيسبب في كلتا الحالتين أخطاء مترابطة على عدة qubit. وبالطبع يجب
ألا ننسى أن gate التحكم-NOT نفسها قد تكون معيبة أيضاً مما قد يسبب أيضاً أخطاء
مترابطة. ومما يزيد قلقنا أن gate ثنائية الـ qubit اللاحقة قد تنشر هذه الأخطاء أكثر.
مثلاً إذا كان لدينا ثلاث gate تحكم-NOT هكذا تماماً كما نجد عند قياس مولّدات المثبّتات X مثلاً فإن خطأً واحداً يمكن أن
ينتشر بسرعة إلى عدة qubit. وإذا حدث هذا داخل كتلة شفرة واحدة مثلاً أي مجموعة
من الـ qubit التي تشفّر معاً qubit منطقي فإن أي شفرة تصحيح أخطاء اخترناها لن يكون لديها
فرصة لأن الشفرات مصممة لتصحيح أخطاء منخفضة الوزن وليس أخطاء عالية الوزن كهذه.
وهذا شيء يجب أن نضعه في الاعتبار في المقدمة والمركز فعلاً ونحن نفكر في الأدوات و
خطوات تصحيح الأخطاء في الـ circuit الكمية المتسامحة مع الأخطاء. أبسط طريقة معروفة للتخفيف من انتشار الأخطاء في الـ circuit
الكمية المتسامحة مع الأخطاء هي تنفيذ الـ gate بشكل عابر وسأشرح ما يعنيه ذلك
بعد قليل. فلنبقِ شكل تنفيذنا المتسامح مع الأخطاء على الشاشة كوسيلة إيضاح بصرية.
الفكرة هنا هي أنه لبعض شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية يمكن تنفيذ بعض الـ gate بشكل عابر وهو ما
يعني تنفيذها باستخدام أدوات هي جداءات تنسور لعمليات حيث كل عملية تعمل فقط على
موضع qubit واحد داخل كل كتلة شفرة. هذا أسهل في الشرح من خلال بعض الأمثلة. المثال الأول و
الأبسط على الأرجح هو التنفيذ العابر لـ gate poly.
الفكرة هي أننا نريد بناء أدوات لكل gate في الـ circuit. وفي جميع الحالات تلك الأدوات
تعمل على كتل شفرة كما نرى لـ gate X و Z في نهاية circuit النقل الكمي. بالطبع
لا يمكننا فك الترميز وتطبيق gate poly ثم إعادة الترميز لأن ذلك سيترك qubit منطقي غير محمي وقد تنتشر الأخطاء
داخل كتلة الشفرة نتيجة إعادة الترميز.
لحسن الحظ لا نحتاج لفعل ذلك طالما نستخدم شفرة مثبّتات لأن كل شفرة مثبّتات تسمح بتطبيق عمليات
poly مباشرة على الـ qubit المنطقية. وفي الواقع يمكننا فعل ذلك بجداء تنسور لـ gate poly
على الـ qubit الفيزيائية المستخدمة في الترميز.
مثلاً إذا نظرنا في شفرة السطح 3×3 التي ظهرت في نهاية الدرس السابق يمكننا تنفيذ gate X و Z على الـ qubit
المنطقي المشفّر بهذه الشفرة بأخذ تنسور gate X و Z مع gate الهوية بالأنماط المقترحة
هنا. هذا تنفيذ عابر لهذه الـ gate لأن كل عملية gate فردية من هذه
تعمل فقط على موضع qubit واحد داخل كل كتلة شفرة.
نحن نستخدم فقط gate على qubit مفرد هنا فهو أمر بديهي نوعاً ما لكن في أي حال أدوات كهذه لن تسبب انتشار
الأخطاء. الآن أي gate فردي في أداة كهذه قد يفشل وهذا سيُدخل
أخطاء لكننا سننفذ دائماً تصحيح الأخطاء فوراً بعد كل أداة. وطالما معدل الخطأ
منخفض بما فيه الكفاية فإن شفرة تصحيح الأخطاء ستصحح تلك الأخطاء.
وكما قلت هذا ممكن دائماً لـ gate poly لكل شفرة مثبّتات.
رغم أنه يجب تحديد النمط الصحيح لـ gate poly في الأدوات لتنفيذ أي عملية poly منطقية تريدها بشكل
صحيح. لمثال آخر يتضمن gate ثنائية الـ qubit هذه المرة يمكننا النظر في التنفيذ العابر
لـ gate التحكم-NOT. بشكل خاص لكل شفرة CSS يمكننا دائماً تنفيذ gate تحكم-NOT
بين qubit منطقيين ببساطة بتنفيذ gate تحكم-NOT على أزواج متقابلة من الـ qubit
الفيزيائية. وهذا يحقق شرط كونه عابراً لأن كل gate تحكم-NOT فردية تعمل فقط
على موضع qubit واحد داخل كل كتلة شفرة. مثلاً gate التحكم-NOT الأولى تعمل فقط على الـ qubit الأعلى
داخل كل كتلة شفرة. وgate التحكم-NOT الثانية تعمل فقط على الـ qubit الثاني من الأعلى وهكذا
دواليك. في هذه الحالة يمكن أن يحدث انتشار للأخطاء لأن gate التحكم-NOT تنشر الأخطاء ولا
توجد طريقة لمنع ذلك. لكن المهم هو أن انتشار الأخطاء لا يحدث أبداً داخل كتلة شفرة واحدة. مثلاً
خطأ X قد يحدث على الـ qubit العلوي من كتلة الشفرة العلوية قبل تنفيذ الأداة مباشرة وgate التحكم-NOT الأولى
داخل الأداة ستنشر ذلك الخطأ إلى الـ qubit العلوي في الكتلة السفلية. لكن الخطأين الناتجين
الآن في كتلتي شفرة منفصلتين. فخطوات تصحيح الأخطاء التي تتم بعد الأداة ستتمكن من تصحيح تلك الأخطاء فردياً لأن تلك
الأخطاء تؤثر فقط على qubit واحد داخل كل كتلة شفرة.
في المقابل إذا حدث انتشار الأخطاء داخل نفس كتلة الشفرة فقد نكون في مشكلة لأن
انتشار الأخطاء يحوّل حينها خطأ منخفض الوزن إلى خطأ أعلى وزناً قد لا تستطيع شفرتنا التعامل معه.
هذا التنفيذ لا يعمل مع شفرات غير CSS لكن طالما نستخدم شفرة CSS يمكننا دائماً تنفيذ gate
التحكم-NOT بشكل عابر بهذه الطريقة. ولمثال آخر كل
gate Clifford يمكن تنفيذها بشكل عابر لشفرة Steane. وفي الواقع لأي شفرة ألوان وهو أحد الأشياء الجيدة حقاً في شفرات
الألوان. بشكل خاص gate Hadamard على qubit منطقي يمكن تنفيذه بتطبيق gate Hadamard فردياً على
كل qubit فيزيائي. وgate S منطقية يمكن تنفيذها ليس بـ gate S على كل qubit بل بـ
gate S المعكوسة على كل qubit فيزيائي. فالخلاصة هي أن التنفيذات العابرة للـ gate هي بطبيعتها
متسامحة مع الأخطاء لأنها لا تنشر أبداً الأخطاء داخل كتلة شفرة واحدة مما يعطي خطوات تصحيح الأخطاء فرصة حقيقية لتصحيح
أياً كانت الأخطاء التي تُدخلها أو تنشرها الـ gate المستخدمة في هذه الأدوات. فهذا رائع وهو
طريقة بسيطة حقاً لبناء أدوات متسامحة مع الأخطاء وهناك شفرات مختلفة تسمح بتنفيذات عابرة لـ gate مختلفة مثل
gate T. لكن للأسف من المستحيل لأي شفرة غير تافهة أن تنفذ
مجموعة شاملة من الـ gate بشكل عابر وهي حقيقة تُعرف بنظرية Eastin-Knill. بمصطلحات تقنية أكثر ما تقوله
هو أنه طالما شفرتنا لديها مسافة اثنين على الأقل فإن مجموعة الـ gate التي يمكن تنفيذها بشكل عابر ستولّد بالضرورة
مجموعة منفصلة من العمليات حتى طور شامل وبالتالي هذه المجموعة ليست شاملة لأن مجموعات الـ gate
الشاملة تولّد بالضرورة عدداً لا نهائياً من العمليات. لن أشرح إثبات هذه النظرية الذي يستخدم بعض
الحقائق الأساسية عن زمر Lie وجبر Lie والتي ليست من متطلبات هذه السلسلة. لكن الفكرة الأساسية هي
أن العائلات اللانهائية من العمليات العابرة لا يمكنها إبقاءنا داخل فضاء الشفرة لأن الفروق الضئيلة
في العمليات العابرة تُقرَّب جيداً بعمليات poly منخفضة الوزن والتي تكتشفها الشفرة كـ
أخطاء. فنحن سعداء جداً عندما نستطيع تنفيذ gate بشكل عابر. لكن لأي شفرة نختارها نعلم أنه ستكون
لدينا دائماً بعض الـ gate التي لا يمكننا تنفيذها بهذه الطريقة. ولذلك نحتاج للبحث عن أدوات بديلة. بموجب
نظرية Eastin-Knill نعلم أنه ليس من الممكن تنفيذ مجموعة شاملة من الـ gate الكمية بشكل عابر حتى
لشفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية بسيطة بمسافة 2. لذا نحتاج لإيجاد طرق أخرى لتنفيذ الـ gate بشكل متسامح
مع الأخطاء على الأقل لبعض الـ gate. إحدى الطرق المعروفة لفعل ذلك هي من خلال استخدام ما يُسمى بالحالات
السحرية. لأغراض هذه المناقشة لنتذكر gate S و T وهي
gate على qubit مفرد معرّفة كما هو موضح هنا على الشاشة. لنلاحظ أيضاً أن أولاً S هي عملية Clifford
وهذا يتبع من تعريفنا لعمليات Clifford. لكن يمكنك أيضاً التحقق من أن اقتران مصفوفة poly بـ S يعطينا دائماً زائد أو ناقص مصفوفة
poly أخرى. وثانياً T ليست عملية Clifford. وفي الواقع إذا جمعنا T مع Hadamard و التحكم-NOT وكلتاهما
عمليتا Clifford نحصل على مجموعة شاملة من الـ gate الكمية. فلا يمكننا تنفيذ gate T
باستخدام عمليات Clifford وقياسات الأساس القياسي وحدها. لكن يمكننا فعلاً تنفيذ gate T باستخدام
عمليات Clifford وقياسات الأساس القياسي إذا كان لدينا بالإضافة لذلك نسخة من الحالة الموضحة هنا على
الشاشة وهي gate T مطبقة على حالة زائد.
هذه الحالة تُسمى الحالة السحرية رغم أنها ليست فريدة في هذا الصدد.
مصطلح الحالة السحرية يُستخدم أيضاً للإشارة إلى حالات مختلفة تلعب دوراً مماثلاً لهذه في تنويعات على هذا المخطط
الكامل. مثلاً هذا الـ circuit الموضح هنا يؤدي المهمة. وليس صعباً جداً التحقق
من ذلك. إليكم الحالة الابتدائية مع النظام العلوي على اليمين. وإذا طبقنا gate التحكم-NOT وبسّطنا نحصل على
الحالة الموضحة هنا.
فإذا قسنا الـ qubit السفلي وحصلنا على صفر وهو يحدث باحتمال 1/2 فلا ننفذ
gate S والخرج هو T مطبقة على ψ.
وإذا قسنا واحد وهو يحدث باحتمال 1/2 بالطبع ننفذ gate S والنتيجة الصافية هي
أن الخرج مرة أخرى T مطبقة على ψ. هذه ليست الطريقة الوحيدة لفعل ذلك بالمناسبة. هناك circuit أخرى مشابهة المظهر
تحقق نفس المهمة لكن هذه إحدى الطرق.
هذا مثال مبسّط نوعاً ما لما يُعرف بالنقل الكمي للـ gate والذي أشرت إليه في الدرس الرابع حيث يُستخدم النقل الكمي
ليس لإرسال qubit بل لتطبيق gate. العلاقة بالنقل الكمي قد لا تكون واضحة تماماً هنا لأنه كما
قلت هذه نسخة مبسطة يمكننا الإفلات بها لأن T قطرية. لكن إذا كنت مهتماً بـ
معرفة المزيد فالكلمات المفتاحية هي النقل الكمي للـ gate.
ويمكننا أيضاً فعل شيء مماثل لتنفيذ gate S حيث هذه المرة الـ gate الوحيدة التي نحتاجها هي gate تحكم-NOT و gate Z مع القياس
وهو مفيد إذا لم يكن لدينا تنفيذ عابر لـ gate S. فهذا مثير للاهتمام لكنه
ليس واضحاً تماماً أن هذا يساعد فعلاً. في حالة تنفيذ gate T مثلاً نحن
نتمكن من تطبيق gate T على حالة مدخلة. لكن لفعل ذلك يبدو أننا نطبق gate T على حالة زائد للحصول على
حالة سحرية. والوضع مماثل لتنفيذ gate S. النقطة هي أننا
لا نحتاج بالضرورة لإنشاء حالة زائد أولاً ثم تطبيق gate T للحصول على حالة سحرية. هناك طرق أخرى ممكنة للحصول على هذه الحالة. وبشكل
خاص يمكننا فعل ذلك بدون الحاجة للقلق بشأن انتشار الأخطاء في أي حساب نعمل عليه لأن الحالات السحرية يمكن إنشاؤها
بشكل منفصل. هذا يسمح بتنفيذ متسامح مع الأخطاء لـ gate T كما سأصف بإيجاز الآن.
أولاً لن نشغل فعلاً الـ circuit البسيط ذو الـ qubit الاثنين الموضح هنا بل سنشغل هذا الـ circuit باستخدام
qubit مشفّرة بأي شفرة تصحيح أخطاء نستخدمها لتنفيذنا المتسامح مع الأخطاء. مما يعني أن
الـ gate الأحادية والقياسات تتم بأدوات متسامحة مع الأخطاء. وهذا يعني أيضاً أننا نحتاج
حالاتنا السحرية مشفّرة أيضاً. فكل شيء سيكون متسامحاً مع الأخطاء طالما نستطيع الحصول على
حالات سحرية مشفّرة. نحن نفترض هنا بالمناسبة أن لدينا بالفعل أداة متسامحة مع الأخطاء لـ gate S. إذا
كنا نستخدم شفرة Steane مثلاً يمكننا ببساطة تنفيذ gate S بشكل عابر. وللشفرات التي لا يعمل فيها ذلك أحد الخيارات هو
استخدام هذا المخطط بالكامل أولاً لتنفيذ gate S بشكل متسامح مع الأخطاء ثم استخدام ذلك التنفيذ هنا.
رغم أن هذا ليس الخيار الوحيد. لكن على أي حال بالعودة إلى التنفيذ السؤال المهم المتبقي هو كيف نحصل على
حالة سحرية مشفّرة بالنظر إلى أنه ليس لدينا بعد تنفيذ متسامح مع الأخطاء لـ gate T لجعل ذلك
بسيطاً؟ والفكرة الأساسية هي أنه يمكننا استخدام عملية احتمالية لإنشاء حالات سحرية مشفّرة. وإذا لم
تنجح فلا بأس. يمكننا ببساطة التخلص من أي محاولات فاشلة والمحاولة مجدداً.
وذلك لا يزعج الحساب الذي نحاول فعلاً تنفيذه لأن إنشاء الحالات السحرية يتم
بشكل منفصل. الطريقة النموذجية لفعل ذلك هي من خلال عملية تُعرف بتقطير الحالات السحرية. وتعمل
هكذا. لدينا circuit معين يُعرف بالمقطّر. ندخل في هذا المقطّر مجموعة من الحالات السحرية
المزعجة ثم نقيس كل المخرجات إلا واحداً. وإذا اشترطنا أن تكون كل نتائج القياس صفراً
فإن ما يخرج هو حالة سحرية أقل ضوضاء والتي يمكن أن تكون أحد الـ qubit المُدخلة في
مقطّر آخر. وتستمر العملية حتى نفشل إما لأن إحدى نتائج القياس غير صفرية فنحاول مجدداً أو نحصل على حالة
سحرية بجودة عالية بما فيه الكفاية لاستخدامها بأمان لتنفيذ gate T في الحساب الذي يهمنا.
هناك طرق معروفة مختلفة لبناء مقطّر كهذا لكنها تعمل جميعاً بنفس الطريقة أساساً وهي أنها مفكّكات ترميز لشفرات مثبّتات
أي أنها معكوسات circuit ترميز وهو أمر جيد لأنه يعني أن المقطّر يمكن أن يكون عملية
Clifford. وأخيراً عملية التقطير هذه تحدث فعلاً على مستوى الـ qubit المنطقي. ففي الواقع كل شيء
يتم باستخدام أدوات للمقطّر والقياسات. هذه العملية يجب أن
تبدأ من مكان ما. لكن طالما معدل الضوضاء ليس مرتفعاً جداً فمن الممكن إنشاء حالات سحرية مزعجة لكن جيدة بما فيه الكفاية
لبدء العملية. مثلاً بتطبيق gate T مزعجة فعلية على qubit في حالة زائد ثم
ترميز ذلك الـ qubit. فكان ذلك وصفاً عالي المستوى جداً لكن آمل أنني أعطيتكم فكرة تقريبية عن كيفية عمل هذا.
الأمر أعقد بكثير من تنفيذ الـ gate بشكل عابر لكنه مع ذلك يوفر طريقة لتنفيذ مجموعة شاملة من الـ gate
الكمية بشكل متسامح مع الأخطاء بينما التنفيذات العابرة وحدها لا تستطيع ذلك. يُقال أحياناً
أن التكلفة الإضافية لاستخدام الحالات السحرية لتنفيذ الـ gate بشكل متسامح مع الأخطاء بهذا الأسلوب ستكون عالية جداً
حيث تذهب الغالبية العظمى من العمل لتقطير الحالات السحرية وتشغيل الحساب الفعلي يصبح أمراً
ثانوياً. لكن هذا في الواقع ليس واضحاً تماماً وهناك تحليلات مفصلة تكشف أن هذه الطريقة
قد تكون عملية فعلاً. هناك عدة مخططات أخرى معروفة لتنفيذ الـ gate بشكل متسامح مع الأخطاء. تشوّه الشفرة وتبديل الشفرة أسماء
مرتبطة ببعض هذه المخططات وطرق جديدة تستمر في التطوير والتحسين لكنني لن أصف تلك
الطرق في هذا الدرس. هناك مسألة مهمة أخرى تتعلق بالتنفيذات المتسامحة مع الأخطاء للـ circuit الكمية و
تتعلق بخطوات تصحيح الأخطاء نفسها. فهذا ليس عن تنفيذ الـ gate بل عن القيام بـ
تصحيح الأخطاء الفعلي. المشكلة هي أنه إذا فكرنا في الـ circuit البسيطة التي
رأيناها أولاً في الدرس الرابع عشر لقياس مولّدات المثبّتات بناءً على تقدير الطور نجد أنها ليست
متسامحة مع الأخطاء بحد ذاتها لأنها قد تسبب انتشار الأخطاء داخل كتلة شفرة واحدة.
هذا يعود لفكرة أن أي شيء يتعلق بالمعلومات الكمية معرّض للأخطاء بما في ذلك الـ circuit المصممة أصلاً
لتصحيح الأخطاء. هذا يبدو مشكلة كبيرة لكن هناك فعلاً عدة حلول معروفة لهذه المشكلة. سأذكر بضعة منها
فقط رغم أنني لن أشرح أياً منها بالتفصيل. وبالمناسبة إذا كنت تحصل على انطباع أن الحوسبة الكمية المتسامحة مع الأخطاء
معقدة وهناك الكثير من التفاصيل للقلق بشأنها فهذا مفهوم تماماً لأنه صحيح. هناك الكثير من الأجزاء المتحركة
هنا ونيتي في هذا الدرس ليست شرح كل التفاصيل بل إعطاؤكم مقدمة أساسية عن كيفية عمل كل
هذا. إحدى طرق تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية المتسامحة مع الأخطاء تُعرف بتصحيح أخطاء Shore على اسم Peter
Shore الذي اقترح هذه الطريقة أولاً. الفكرة هي تنفيذ كل قياس متلازمة باستخدام ما يُسمى بحالة قطة
وهي نفس الشيء كحالة GHZ عندما يكون لدينا ثلاثة qubit لكن يمكن تعميمها لأي عدد من الـ qubit يطابق وزن مولّد
المثبّت الذي ننوي قياسه. بشكل خاص الـ circuit الموضح هنا يعمل لقياس مولّد مثبّت. ويمكن
إثبات أن هذه الطريقة لا تسبب انتشار الأخطاء داخل كتلة شفرة.
هي تتطلب إنشاء حالة القطة نفسها. ولجعلها تعمل بشكل موثوق في وجود أخطاء و gate قد تكون معيبة تتطلب الطريقة فعلاً
أن نشغل circuit كهذه بشكل متكرر ونستنتج أين قد حدثت أخطاء مختلفة أثناء
العملية. طريقة بديلة تُعرف بتصحيح أخطاء Steane اقترحها أولاً Andrew Steane وهذه
الطريقة تعمل بشكل مختلف وتعمل فقط مع شفرات CSS. في هذه الطريقة لا ننفذ فعلاً قياسات المتلازمة على الحالات الكمية المشفّرة
في الـ circuit الذي نحاول تشغيله بل ننشر الأخطاء عمداً إلى نظام مساحة عمل
ثم نقيس ذلك النظام ونكتشف الأخطاء كلاسيكياً. هذا الشكل الموضح هنا يوضح كيفية فعل ذلك لأخطاء X وفي هذه الحالة
qubit مساحة العمل تُهيّأ مبدئياً كترميز لحالة زائد. فهذا أساساً
تنفيذ عابر لـ gate تحكم-NOT والتي لا يجب أن تفعل شيئاً لأن الهدف في حالة زائد. لكن إذا
كانت هناك أخطاء X في الـ qubit العلوية ستنتشر للنظام السفلي وستُكتشف. هناك أيضاً طريقة مماثلة لاكتشاف أخطاء Z
غير موضحة هنا. وهناك أيضاً طريقة ذات صلة تُعرف بتصحيح أخطاء Knill اقترحها أولاً Manny Knill
وهي مبنية على النقل الكمي بدلاً من gate تحكم-NOT عابرة وهذا يسمح لها بالعمل مع أي شفرة مثبّتات
وليس فقط شفرات CSS.
آخر ما سأناقشه في هذا الدرس هو نظرية مهمة جداً تُعرف بنظرية العتبة. إليكم صياغة غير رسمية
نوعاً ما للنظرية. تقول أنه إذا كان لدينا أي circuit كمي يحتوي على n من الـ gate حيث n يمكن أن تكون كبيرة كما نشاء فمن
الممكن تنفيذ ذلك الـ circuit بدقة عالية باستخدام circuit كمي مزعج شريطة أن مستوى الضوضاء
يكون تحت قيمة عتبة معينة مستقلة عن n. وعلاوة على ذلك ليس مكلفاً جداً فعل ذلك بمعنى
أن حجم الـ circuit المزعج المطلوب هو من رتبة n ضرب قوة ثابتة معينة من لوغاريتم
n. لصياغة النظرية بشكل أكثر رسمية يتطلب تحديد نموذج الضوضاء وهو ما لن أفعله في هذا الدرس.
يمكن مثلاً إثباتها لنموذج الضوضاء العشوائية المستقلة الذي ذكرته سابقاً حيث تحدث الأخطاء
بشكل مستقل في كل موقع ممكن في الـ circuit باحتمال أصغر تماماً من قيمة العتبة هذه. لكن يمكن أيضاً
إثباتها لنماذج ضوضاء أكثر عمومية حيث يمكن أن يكون هناك ارتباط بين الأخطاء. الآن هذه نتيجة
نظرية والطريقة النموذجية لإثباتها لا تترجم بالضرورة إلى شيء سنفعله فعلاً عملياً لكنها مع ذلك نظرية
مهمة جداً من الناحية العملية. والسبب هو أنها تقول أساساً أنه لا يوجد حاجز أساسي أمام تنفيذ
حسابات كمية باستخدام مكونات مزعجة.
طالما معدل الخطأ لهذه المكونات تحت قيمة العتبة هذه يمكن استخدامها لبناء circuit كمية موثوقة بأي حجم
تعسفي. طريقة أخرى للقول هي أنه لو لم تكن النظرية صحيحة لكان من الصعب تخيل أن الحوسبة الكمية واسعة النطاق
ستصبح حقيقة يوماً. هناك الكثير من التفاصيل التقنية في البراهين الرسمية لهذه النظرية والتي لن أحاول
إيصالها. لكنني سأحاول شرح الفكرة الأساسية على مستوى عالٍ. وسأحاول أيضاً ربط الفكرة الأساسية
بشكل فضفاض بما قد نتوقع حدوثه عملياً. فلنفترض أن هذا هو الـ circuit. إنه نفس الـ circuit الذي
تحدثنا عنه طوال الدرس. لكن مرة أخرى يمكننا تخيل أن الـ circuit أكبر وأعقد بكثير من هذا. نريد
تنفيذ هذا الـ circuit لكن كل مكوناتنا مزعجة. وبافتراض أننا نستخدم نموذج الضوضاء العشوائية المستقلة
فقط للتبسيط هناك احتمال P تحدث فيه الأخطاء بشكل مستقل في كل موقع ممكن.
إذا كان الـ circuit أكبر بكثير من مقلوب هذا الاحتمال P فيمكننا أن نكون متأكدين تقريباً أن
التنفيذ المباشر له لن يعمل بشكل صحيح. لذا نمر بكل عملية تنفيذ الـ circuit
بشكل متسامح مع الأخطاء كما ناقشت حتى هذه النقطة في الدرس ونسأل أنفسنا السؤال الذي طرحته سابقاً: هل نجعل الأمور
أفضل أم أسوأ؟ إذا كان الاحتمال P الذي يمثل احتمال الخطأ لكل مكون من مكوناتنا كبيراً جداً فهذا
لن يساعد تماماً كما أن شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit لا تساعد إذا كان احتمال الخطأ أعلى من 3 وثلاثة أرباع بالمئة تقريباً.
بشكل خاص لقد جعلنا الـ circuit أكبر. فهناك مواقع أكثر بكثير حيث يمكن أن تقع أخطاء.
لكن إذا كانت P صغيرة بما فيه الكفاية فهذا سيساعد. وما سنفعله فعلياً هو تقليل احتمال
الخطأ للحساب المنطقي الذي ننفذه. فلنفكر في هذا بـ
تفصيل أكثر قليلاً. ولرؤية الأفكار الرئيسية في أبسط إطار ممكن لنفترض أننا نستخدم شفرة Steane ذات الـ 7 qubit لتصحيح
الأخطاء والتي تسمح بتصحيح خطأ واحد على الأكثر لكل كتلة شفرة. فلكي يحدث خطأ منطقي
في الـ circuit الأصلي يجب أن يكون لدينا خطأان على الأقل يقعان في نفس كتلة الشفرة لتنفيذنا المتسامح
مع الأخطاء.
مع الأخذ بالاعتبار أن هناك طرقاً كثيرة مختلفة لوجود خطأين أو أكثر في نفس كتلة الشفرة يمكن الجدال بأن احتمال خطأ
منطقي في كل موقع في الـ circuit الأصلي هو على الأكثر C ضرب P تربيع حيث C عدد يعتمد على الشفرة وعلى
الأدوات التي نستخدمها. لكن الأهم أنه لا يعتمد على حجم الـ circuit الأصلي.
فإذا كانت P أصغر من مقلوب C وهو الرقم الذي يمكننا اعتباره قيمة العتبة فإن هذا
يترجم إلى تقليل في الأخطاء. فعملنا الشاق في تنفيذ الـ circuit بشكل متسامح مع الأخطاء يؤتي
ثماره. لكن معدل الخطأ الجديد هذا قد لا يزال مرتفعاً جداً لكي يعمل الـ circuit بالكامل بشكل صحيح. فنحتاج للقيام
بالمزيد. عملياً الشيء الطبيعي عند هذه النقطة هو اختيار شفرة أفضل وأدوات أفضل لدفع معدل
الخطأ للأسفل إلى نقطة يُرجّح فيها أن التنفيذ سيعمل.
نظرياً طريقة بسيطة للجدال بأن هذا ممكن هي التسلسل. بعبارة أخرى نفكر
في التنفيذ المتسامح مع الأخطاء للـ circuit الأصلي كـ circuit منطقي جديد. ثم ننفذه بشكل متسامح
مع الأخطاء. ثم نفعل ذلك مرة أخرى ومرة أخرى بقدر ما نحتاج. ويتبين أن هذا يقلل الأخطاء
بسرعة كبيرة. وهكذا تُثبت نظرية العتبة عادة على الورق.
سأعطيكم فقط فكرة تقريبية جداً عن كيفية انخفاض معدل الخطأ مع ترك التفاصيل التقنية الكثيرة المطلوبة
لإثبات ذلك رسمياً. نبدأ باحتمال الخطأ P لمكوناتنا الأصلية. وإذا نفذنا
الـ circuit بشكل متسامح مع الأخطاء ينخفض الخطأ بعامل C ضرب P. وإذا عاملنا بعدها تنفيذنا المتسامح
كـ circuit منطقي ونفذناه بشكل متسامح مع الأخطاء نحصل على انخفاض مماثل في معدل الخطأ. لكن
إذا فكرنا في معدل الخطأ الفعلي للـ circuit الأصلي نجد أنه ينخفض أكثر لأننا
الآن نستبدل معدل الخطأ P بـ C ضرب P تربيع لأن ذلك هو معدل الخطأ الفعلي بعد المستوى الأول من التنفيذ المتسامح
مع الأخطاء. تحديداً بعد القليل من الجبر نجد أن الخطأ ينخفض إلى C ضرب P
تكعيب ضرب P. وإذا فعلناه مرة أخرى يصبح معدل الخطأ C ضرب P أس 7 ضرب P. وإذا
استمرينا في ذلك لمجموع K من المستويات نجد أن الخطأ يتقلص بشكل أسّي مضاعف في K. فلا
نحتاج لفعل ذلك مرات كثيرة لجعل معدل الخطأ صغيراً للغاية.
في الوقت نفسه الـ circuit تكبر في الحجم لكن الحجم يزداد فقط بشكل أسّي مفرد في K لأنه مع كل
مستوى من التسامح مع الأخطاء ينمو حجم الـ circuit بعامل محدد بالحد الأقصى لحجم
أدواتنا. وعندما يُجمع كل ذلك معاً ويُختار عدد مناسب
لمستويات التسلسل نحصل على نظرية العتبة. لكن كما أشرت بالفعل هناك الكثير من التفاصيل المطلوبة لجعل هذا رسمياً. إذن
ما هي قيمة العتبة هذه في الواقع؟ حسناً إنها تعتمد على الشفرة وعلى الأدوات التي
نستخدمها. لشفرة Steane مع تقطير الحالات السحرية إنها ضئيلة جداً وعلى الأرجح غير قابلة للتحقيق
عملياً. لكن باستخدام شفرات السطح وأحدث الأدوات قُدّرت بحوالي 1%. وهو ليس
سيئاً. ومع اكتشاف شفرات وطرق جديدة يمكننا أن نتوقع بشكل معقول أن تزداد بينما في نفس الوقت
مستوى الضوضاء في المكونات التي نبنيها سينخفض. الوصول إلى النقطة التي
يمكن فيها تنفيذ حسابات كمية واسعة النطاق بشكل متسامح مع الأخطاء لن يكون سهلاً ولن يحدث بين ليلة وضحاها.
لكن هذه النظرية مع التقدم في الشفرات الكمية وعتاد الحوسبة الكمية الذي شهدناه حتى الآن
تمنحنا التفاؤل الذي نحتاجه للاستمرار في الدفع نحو هذا الهدف النهائي وهو بناء
حاسوب كمي واسع النطاق متسامح مع الأخطاء. وهذا نهاية الدرس ونهاية السلسلة.
أتمنى بصدق أنكم وجدتم قيمة في السلسلة وإذا كان الأمر كذلك يرجى التفكير في التوصية بها لزميل أو صديق.
تأكدوا أيضاً من زيارة IBM Quantum Learning للمزيد من الدورات والدروس التعليمية واشتركوا في قناة Qiskit
على YouTube إذا لم تكونوا قد فعلتم بعد حتى تبقوا على اطلاع بإصداراتنا المستقبلية من المحتوى. شكراً
لمتابعتكم.